all the way back in 2016 we learned that
a new armored Core game was in the works
so back then I remember thinking man I
really should go back and play all of
the old armored Core games I need to
understand why people love this series
how many games could there even be five
six but then I realized the truth there
are 15 unique armored Core games and
that's not even counting the three PSP
remakes or the multiple discs that some
of these games have not to mention the
arena modes the branching Mission paths
hard mode New Game Plus optional
objectives at the lore that makes even
my head spin these are complex
challenging and extremely intricate
games and while they never really hit
mainstream appeal it was armored Core
and its dedicated fans that kept from
software afloat for many many years and
then sadly it was those same fans who
had to watch their favorite franchise
take a back seat when Souls became from
software's Breadwinner instead so I
wanted to experience these games the
same way that the old fans did not with
emulators but with old hardware and all
of the authenticity and all of the
frustration that comes with that so many
eBay purchases and over 2 000 US Dollars
later I had them three used consoles two
retro capture devices and 18 absurdly
expensive old video games I was ready so
I went back to the first armored Core
released all the way back in 1997 and I
was thrown straight into the deep end
you must battle against the opponent AC
and survive if you survive you'll be
considered a raven that's all good luck
this is how armored Core begins with you
in a fight for your life taking fire as
you frantically run around the arena and
attempt to puzzle out the controls
there's literally no guide or tips
nothing just from software saying yeah
you'll figure it out one by one I
Stumble through the controls and try to
commit them to Memory X to boost Square
to shoot triangle to change weapon but
when it comes to aiming something feels
wrong because these enemies can fly
right which means I need a way to aim up
or down at them and since moving
forwards and backwards are already bound
here that means
yeah so looking up and down is bound to
the left and right back triggers and
that sucks I'm gonna be honest even
after beating all of these armored Core
games I'm sitting here now writing this
script and I honestly could not tell you
from memory which back trigger moves the
camera up or down if there was ever a
time I needed to look up at something
there was like a 50 chance I was gonna
look down at the floor instead but
somehow I pushed through and I do
eventually learn how to get good these
games will simply not allow you to
progress if you don't it's classic from
software even all those years ago they
throw you in the deep end and expect the
best from you will you sink or swim the
test is over from this moment on you are
a raven
this is the Raven's Nest here you can
assemble your Mech but you have no new
parts right now so you go to the shop
where you have no money so you end up at
the mission board where you become a
wage slave to the two biggest
corporations Chrome and murakumo who are
in this desperate battle with each other
for Supremacy but your first mission is
from the city guard who are very angry
because some workers are protesting in a
nearby Factory and since it's not a good
look for the city guard to use lethal
force on you know citizens innocent
civilians they give you 14 000 credits
to do it instead
so you get to it the workers crude
cranes and worker MTS are no match for
your armored War Machine and and you
walk away with 14 000 credits except
wait you have to pay for the bullets you
used on those evil protesters and you'll
also need to repair the damage you took
during the mission as well don't worry
there are always more striking workers
who need to be taught a lesson and
there's always someone else's Dirty Work
to profit from I was making pretty good
money that is until the third mission
where I was tasked with rescuing a truck
filled with chemical weaponry and I
proceeded to promptly blow up the truck
and I assumed that I would just get to
try again but no instead the mission
completed and gave me my reward minus
1.4 k for ammunition minus 4.4 k for
repairs and minus 200 credits in
compensation for that poor civilians car
that I crushed during the heat of battle
so I hadn't just failed the mission I
had actually lost money attempting it I
knew I was going to be morally bankrupt
going into this game but turns out you
can be financially bankrupt as well if
you play poorly enough
looking back at my footage now I
realized I was way too hesitant to spend
credits probably because new parts and
their stats were just so overwhelming to
me eventually though I would realize
that you can't really go too wrong
spending credits in these games if it's
expensive chances are it's an upgrade
and even if you regret buying it you can
always sell those parts back to the shop
for the same price that you bought them
at and just buy something else instead
this is a game that will not stop you
making mistakes but it won't always
punish you for those mistakes either
so I had no idea what I wanted to buy
from the shop but I had heard whispers
about a legendary weapon that existed in
this game and I knew I needed to try it
I needed to figure out why it was so
popular
called the carousel an energy rifle that
you actually can't get in the shop
instead it was one of the many hidden
Parts in this game these are parts that
you actually have to hunt down and pick
up during missions I had read somewhere
that the karasawa was hidden behind some
explosive Barrels in an early mission
and it was easy enough to find
okay so this thing was insane it
dramatically increased my Firepower and
most enemies would die in just a few
shots but it wasn't without its
downsides for one the karasawa was
extremely heavy so I realized I needed
to buy heavy legs in order to
accommodate that weight the karasawa
also has pretty limited ammo so I
equipped some light missiles as backup
it's really interesting how just
changing one part of your build can
fundamentally change your build new
parts will introduce new problems that
need to be solved and by solving these
your knowledge about parts and stats
will just natural really increase and I
think that's really cool I also realized
that the karasawa was an energy weapon
so it costs energy to fire that meant I
needed to take a closer look at my
generator and I needed to decide whether
I needed a generator with high energy
regen or a generator with high capacity
High region would make me better in
prolonged fights but high capacity would
allow me to fire a ton more shots and
overwhelm enemies in the short term I'm
going to repeat this point so many times
over the course of this video but I
think it's really amazing that armored
Core allows you to change such
fundamental things about your gameplay
anyway the final thing I learned from
the karasawa was that its energy ammo
was actually free and in the early game
when you're strapped for cash that's an
amazing thing and so I was learning so
many lessons here that would serve me
well in all of the armored Core games to
follow now the karasawa was powerful but
it it's not like it made the game easy
looking up and down was still a pain
some missions had very unclear
objectives and there were so many
missions where I just spent ages
navigating Mazes of corridors with
agonizingly slow turn speeds only to die
or run out of ammo right at the end so
most of the time I was just craving
single combat against enemy ACS those
were my favorite fights and if the fight
had some questionable voice acting to
laugh at well even better
I don't know anything about those things
here
what did you hear forget it prepare to
die there was also a frustrating moment
at the end where I died to the final
boss and then I got a unique cutscene
this wasn't just a unique cutscene it
was a game over screen so for the first
time in hours of play I discovered this
and it booted me back to my last Save
which I had made so long ago so it was
just so much fun having to redo all
these missions again and try to remember
what I had changed in my build that was
great and you might say well you should
have just saved but this was the PS1 era
you know saving took time menus were
slow so I didn't bother to save until I
had this experience but I pushed through
this last level I was stuck on was
tricky because it required me to clear
rooms and rooms of enemies really
efficiently so I had to make sure to
manage my health and ammo so that I had
the resources required for the final
boss it was fun overcoming it except
this was not the final boss and I wasn't
done not by a long shot the true final
mission takes place at the Ravens Nest
headquarters where a mysterious band has
broken in and left behind a set of
floating Minds now the Raven's Nest
itself wants you to come in and
dismantle them the the first part of
this mission is simple enough I had to
take out one small room of five easy
enemies making sure I used my blade to
conserve ammo because the next room was
considerably more difficult as it was so
packed full of enemies that my
PlayStation lagged uncontrollably this
room was tricky but easier with some
practice and I had plenty of
opportunities to practice because while
your ammunition and health is restored
after completing this second room if you
fail after this point you'll get game
over and have to go all the way back to
your last save so for part two of the
mission you find yourself in this vast
Square hallway lucky for you there's a
way up unlucky for you the devs forgot
what game they were making halfway
through and decided to start making a
platformer instead but this isn't Doodle
Jump okay this is armored Core remember
looking up and down in this game is
excruciating and this hallway is is
vertical so you have to look up to where
you're going and then you have to look
down to make sure you have your Landing
secured every time because all of these
platforms are moving they're moving in
different directions as well and all at
different speeds some will even run into
each other and slide you off which is
great and then there's the turrets that
are attached on the top and bottom of
many platforms which will give you knock
back and stagger and damage while you
attempt your Ascent they don't do much
damage and they don't take that many
hits to defeat but oh man you're gonna
really miss that HP and ammo when you
finally get to the top because the worst
is yet to come this is just a
frustrating
time-consuming interlude for you to
enjoy every single time you have to redo
this mission
and unless you're an armored Core God or
using save states on an emulator you
will have to redo this Mission and
that's because of what or who comes next
name of AC
ball
if you had ever looked at the ranking
menu in the Ravens Nest you would have
seen a list of all the enemy ACS in the
game and nine ball is the top ranked AC
piloted by someone named hustler1 and
he's top rank for a reason just watch
this attempt of me fighting him
foreign
after getting over it 20 minutes later I
was back for round two which went like
this
on on and on it went until I simply gave
up nine ball is overpowered literally he
actually has something unlocked called
human plus which is an overpowered state
that you can unlock if you go into 50
000 credits in debt which is cool but I
didn't do that so nine ball can fly
better than me he's faster than me he
has better Weaponry than me he
approaches from above with the high
ground and he forces you to fight by
aiming up and down because of the nature
of the vertical Arena that you're in
plus you've already been weakened
mentally and physically by playing jump
King for the last 10 minutes every time
you attempt this so I decided to not
fight at all I decided to run for my
[__] life past this absolute Terror
to see if I could just get past him and
complete the mission that way on my
first Escape run I choked and I missed
the tiny hole that you're supposed to
fly into and then on my second try I
made it but somehow nine ball managed to
get in after me
back then I guess I had one thought in
my mind here and that was to flee to run
down the corridor in Terror away from
this black and red AC that had been
killing me all day
the AI Core that you destroy at the end
is somehow part of nine balls
Consciousness and you destroyed mission
complete
[Music]
thank God I don't have to fight that guy
again
next up was armored Core project
fantasma which was released only a few
months after the first armored Corps
they were able to do this because while
project fantasma can still be played as
its own Standalone game it's perhaps
more accurate to call this an expansion
the game essentially plays the same as
the first one except with New Missions
new parts and some rebalancing to Old
Parts you can even transfer your save
from the first game over to this one if
you want to continue with your previous
AC build and all of its parts which is
really cool and this is basically how
all of the armored Core games work the
easiest way to understand how they're
all connected is when they're arranged
like this each row represents a
generation of armored Core games where
your save can continue within the
generation there's gen 1 for the PS1 Gen
2 3 and 3.5 for the PS2 then Gen 4 and 5
for the PS3 and Xbox 360. Generations 1
to 3.5 play quite similarly but this
series would eventually change radically
in generation 4 and then again in
generation 5 as you'll see later on
anyway I wanted to try a new build in
project fantasma and I'd since learned
that the most defining part of your
build are your legs it's kind of like
the RPG equivalent of choosing a class
they determine how fast you move how
fast you turn the nature of your
movement but perhaps most importantly
how much weight you can carry first I
tried some tread legs tread legs allow
you to carry extremely heavy loads and
even allow you to fire heavy back
weapons while you're moving or flying
which no other Lake Parts can do however
this comes at the cost of your movement
and flying ability and one mission was
enough for me to decide that this was
not for me
like imagine completing every mission in
the game going this slowly
what I ended up settling on were quad
legs quad legs are kind of like tread
legs in the sense that they allow you to
fire heavy back weapons while you're
moving though you can't fly while you do
so but unlike tread legs quad legs exist
on a bit of a spectrum where you can
equip heavy load-bearing quads but also
fast lightweight quads as well I opted
for the latter now lightweight ACS are
kind of hard to put together because
there's a lower weight limit which
prevents you from choosing stronger
weightier parts so putting this Build
Together would require a lot of trial
and error
but I realized that there was no better
place for this build process than in a
place called The Arena
in the arena you fight exclusively
against enemy ACS in one-on-one combat
ranking up and earning credits as you go
and while enemy ACS are some of the
toughest enemies that you can face in
these games there are no ammo costs here
and you can only really benefit from
these fights but best of all it teaches
you about different enemy builds and it
shows you what works what doesn't work
and it shows you the limits of your own
build it's the perfect space to refine
and adjust your AC into a machine that's
capable of taking on some of the hardest
fights in the game and that's what my
build quickly became a fast lightweight
quad with machine gun arms and ammo
canisters on its back a build designed
to do one thing really well and that was
to run circles around my opponents
staying outside of their FCS lock box
and keeping them in my own it's hard to
explain just how satisfying it is to
refine your build in these games and to
see it all come together perfectly at
the end you know you solve energy
problems weight problems ammo problems
you compromise on some parts but then
you stand your ground on others and if
you're lucky you'll end up with a build
that is entirely your own you know how
to play it you know what its weaknesses
are you know its strengths you know
exactly what challenges went into
creating it and it's yours so when I
went back into missions and I realized
that machine gun ammo costs were going
to put me deep into debt it was easy for
me to tweak my build into a more cost
efficient one for most missions because
I understood how to undo certain parts
of my build but for the final mission I
wheeled out my lightweight expensive AC
killer and went to town the final fight
was against Stinger who's a bit of a
joke honestly at least compared to nine
ball in the previous game Stinger's
strategy was to shoot out so many
Rainbow bullets that my FPS would drop
to unplayable levels and it almost
worked because I actually ran out of
ammo in this fight and assumed that I'd
lost so at this point I actually gave up
and went close to him so that he could
just kill me faster and get it over with
but then this happened
his own missiles dealt the final piece
of damage to himself
pretty fitting way for this guy to go
out my AC gloriously flies into the roof
and that's the end of project fantasma
I felt like I was getting pretty good at
the series
from software were watching just waiting
to tear me back down again because the
next game was armored Core master of
Arena and I legitimately felt dread when
I put in the disc loaded up that first
mission and watched this cutscene don't
shoot me I'm leaving now
awesome
and what another one
with the top range Arena AC doing here
and I heard you've been looking for me
[Music]
and I don't care who you are no one can
defeat me
none bull was back and this time it was
personal on a few levels because I
wanted revenge on nine ball for him
shaming me in the first game you know in
front of all my YouTube viewers as well
but apparently my character in the game
wanted Revenge as well
is the one you've been looking for huh
Lana is your contact at the Raven's Nest
and mail from her reads when we first
met on the network you mentioned
becoming a raven because there was
someone you wanted to kill AC name nine
ball pilot Hustler one top-ranked AC in
the arena that is all we know she
comments that anyone who attempts to
face nine ball in battle will surely be
destroyed that if we're really serious
about this then she can arrange it so
that we will one day fight him so Lana
immediately passes us a mission from
progtech who manufacture AC parts they
want us to put down some rampaging
robots in their Factory and in return
they'll give us some free parts and
sponsor us in the arena what follows is
this glorious mix of mission and Arena
gameplay sometimes your mission board
will be completely empty and all you can
access is the arena which you'll need to
progress in in order to unlock missions
again and then sometimes it's the
reverse where the arena is locked off
because there's an urgent mission need
to complete for your sponsor and it's
this balance the way that the arena and
Mission gameplay is interwoven that
makes master of Arena easily rank within
my top three armored Core games because
the pacing is just phenomenal in other
games sometimes missions would feel like
a grind and sometimes doing the arena
would just feel like an optional side
quest but in this game missions had me
feel like I was strengthening my
relationship with my sponsor and when I
progressed in the arena I knew it was in
pursuit of a goal to rise through the
ranks so that I could one day have the
right to challenge nine ball who is
formidable in the story of this game
just as he's formidable in a gameplay
sense as well so I continued to chip
away at the missions and in the arena I
was a demon I was this red AC wielding
the karasawa and a Moonlight sword and
some really fast legs
these legs were so fast that I didn't
really need my boosters which meant that
I had more energy for shooting my
karasawa while grounded with this build
I flew through the arena and if I was
ever having trouble with an opponent it
would be because they were flying but if
they were flying I would just take them
to the garage which was an arena level
that limited their flight capabilities
and kept them on the ground with me so I
didn't have to touch the accursed R2 and
L2 triggers I was feeling pretty
confident and then the final fight with
nine ball arrived
[Music]
thank you I thought this fight went
pretty well got him on the first try
except that wasn't the end
operation the ACs the Ravens
all of these were formed by me
creating the world and humankind with it
and that's the duty to which I've been
entrusted
and those who wield towards power
[Music]
and those who only bring chaos
they're not part of the program
phase two has you fighting two nine
balls and that's exactly as hard as it
sounds
the reason there's two is because it's
been revealed that the nine balls are
able to be mass produced and they
actually aren't piloted by a Human
Instead they're controlled by a highly
Advanced combat AI that thinks it can
rebuild the World by manufacturing
conflict as long as they're the
strongest Raven which is why it has to
take you out which it does repeatedly
quickly I realize that it's extremely
important that you do well in the first
fight against the single nine ball
because your health and demo that
remains is what you'll need to take on
the other two at once and after a ton of
time consuming resets I realized that
there was an upper level to the Dual
nine wall fight which could be used to
potentially separate the two and help
you to fight one at a time
finally I was Victorious
there's this kind of like absurd giddy
dread that I've only ever really
experienced playing from soft games that
feeling that even though you've pushed
yourself to the Limit the challenge
actually isn't over yet
our system checks are complete
[Music]
all right
I'll Target verify commencing
hostilities
[Music]
defenses damaged halting combat and
returning to the nest
this third phase is extremely tough and
it also takes a while to learn it
because you have to defeat one nine ball
and then you have to defeat the two nine
balls before you even get a chance to
practice this fight and those two fights
were hard enough so you don't get that
many chances to practice but eventually
I learned that nine ball serif as he's
called Always begins to fight by running
at you with his blade which sends energy
waves and requires a well-timed boost
jump for you to evade it after that
he'll transform into this little rocket
ship and zoom around the arena shooting
missiles and trying to get behind you
before transforming back into an attack
phase and just closing the distance with
his blade and his pulse rifle once again
over and over I tried to defeat him and
over and over again I lost
but I had heard rumors of something
a controller technique that I thought
might just be able to help me it's
something called the legendary armored
Core grip some said that it was a meme
others said that by holding your
controller backwards you could get full
access to every button at once which
would allow for perfect control of your
AC so I gave it a try
foreign
[Music]
ly after countless attempts at Phase One
and about 16 victories in phase two I
managed to overcome phase three with a
little bit of skill and a lot of luck
and I was just joking about using the
armored Core grip
or was I
anyway nine ball was dead thank God I
don't have to fight that guy again
next up armored Core 2 I was excited for
this because this was a PS2 game and I
had been eyeing that PS2 controller off
to my side for a while now just knowing
it had what I wanted Jewel analog sticks
I couldn't wait to be able to aim
properly so I grabbed the controller
moved the sticks and they didn't work
what for some unfathomable reason from
software had decided to stick with the
back triggers for camera control in this
game which I just don't understand the
solution was right there it's insane to
me that this wasn't a design priority
for them maybe there's a good reason for
this but I don't know anyway let's talk
story so armored Core 2 takes place 67
years after the events of Master of
Arena when a cataclysmic event called
the Great destruction forced mankind
underground eventually however mankind
discovered the pre-war Mars immigration
project and started to set up colonies
on the red planet where Wars over
resources would inevitably break out
once more it's a compelling story but I
wanted my story to begin in a really
unique way this time so this time I
didn't start with a single Mission
instead I committed for some reason to
playing exclusively in the arena until I
had defeated every single opponent and
become the top ranked Raven this ended
up being an extremely memorable
experience for me and while the arena
doesn't incur repair and ammo costs it
doesn't exactly give you many credits at
the start either so there was a limit to
which parts I could afford when
attempting to outsmart my enemies so for
me it was very important to read these
character descriptions before each fight
and I loved how much story and insight
each one revealed some characters were
in the arena to pay off gambling debts
some were here to show off their new
parts they had for sale or I distinctly
remember 45 who was a girl piloting a
Mech in order to earn money to feed her
starving family feels bad but most
importantly some descriptions revealed
the enemy ai's preferred strategies and
weaknesses for example this guy was
famously bad at energy management and
then there was another one who would
Panic if you pressured them and then
some enemies were just pure comedy at
one point I met bullet Dragon a man who
was in the arena because he loved the
sound of machine guns and he only fought
so that he could afford more ammo I
could couldn't outpace him with my own
machine gun so I outlasted him and he
flat out I don't know if this was a
glitch or anything but he just seemed to
decide to leave the arena when he
started to run out of machine gun ammo
and then there was supersonic who was a
character who spent all his money on the
fastest Parts like he was just here to
build for Speed and nothing else and
then poor guy he actually went so fast
that he flew out of bounds in the arena
and I won 10 out of 10. it's in armored
Core 2's Arena that I experimented with
basically every weapon type in the shop
there were so many ways to express your
creativity in the builds in this game
and constantly trying to exploit new
enemy weaknesses taught me so much about
the pros and cons of various Weaponry
but the best lesson I think I Learned
was from number 19 AC name Mass pilot
name bulk
guess what his build is yeah so his
build was designed to just stay alive
while his opponents ran out of ammo
which I did many times and in trying to
overcome him I found it my new best
friend the ewg mg saw a machine gun with
a thousand rounds of ammo which allowed
me to focus on one strategy unrelenting
offense and with this gun I went all the
way towards top rank but on the way I
met count One Pilot name number one one
one one rank 11. he's obsessed with the
number one and has put a great deal of
effort into his current position he'd
rather be ranked 11th than first as it
has twice as many ones I realized even
his weapon arms looked like two sets of
ones so you gotta respect the commitment
but in retrospect his weapon arms would
end up being the key because my machine
gun circling strategy ended up being
useless against the top ranked AC Aries
who had the Firepower and the Turning
ability to completely counter my
strategy so I built for power to
overwhelm him instead and that's where I
got the idea from number 11 who used
weapon arms and with these bazooka arms
I absolutely destroyed Aries to become
number one one one was enough for me now
I can actually start playing the game
and when I finally did start the
missions it didn't matter that my
machine gun ammo was extremely expensive
I was an arena millionaire and when I
finally got to the last mission and
there was this sequence where I needed
to fight enemies that I couldn't lock
onto the arena had already taught me
what to do instead of brute forcing the
final fight with sheer stubbornness like
I had in previous games I actually used
my shop knowledge to come up with a
better build and a better strategy and
equipped with rockets and grenade
cannons that didn't really need lock-on
to function properly I made the final
sequence way easier for myself
the final boss's name is Leos Klein and
interestingly it's implied that he was
actually the player character from
master of Arena and I love these little
callbacks there's a depth to the
storytelling that I was discovering
although I'll admit 99 of the
storytelling was going over my head as I
was just so focused on the gameplay
but even though I'm not paying much
attention to the story in these
playthroughs yet anyway even I can tell
when it's missing and nowhere did story
feel more absent than in armored Court 2
another rage
big selling point in this expansion
seems to be the sheer amount of missions
I felt like most of these games had an
average of between 20 or 30 missions
before you hit an ending but in another
age there are a hundred missions in the
game and whereas in some other games you
can skip certain missions or just have
them go away if you fail all 100
Missions in another age are mandatory
now I'ma be honest every armored Core
game does have its fair share of very
badly designed missions missions where
you get lost in Endless corridors with
unclear objectives or missions where you
go out of bounds or are forced to do
platforming for some reason and another
age did have tons of missions that I
hated but the worst in my opinion were
missions that your AC could be
fundamentally incompatible with for
example there was a mission here that
required me to ascend a long Corridor
and I just couldn't with so many of my
builds and don't get me wrong I love
reworking my AC to solve combat puzzles
but having my build be fundamentally
incompatible with some mandatory
missions was frustrating to say the
least
I guess this is why armored Core 6 might
be adding jump pads huh but then there
is a bright side to having mandatory
missions in that it does at least force
you to try different things but more
importantly it forces you to get good
for example perhaps the most memorable
mission for me in another age was this
one where you have to fight not one not
two but three enemy Ravens all at the
same time and that is again exactly as
hard as it sounds one of the enemies was
a heavy tank build that can harass you
if you leave it alive another is
extremely mobile and is equipped with
powerful Weaponry that will take you
down very very quickly and the third AC
luckily isn't much of a threat at all
but they still do serve as a distraction
and require precious time and ammo to
take down so once you have stock of your
opponents you have to come up with a
strategy and make sure your AC design
accommodates that strategy and then you
have to make sure you have the skill to
actually put that strategy into action
after a few attempts I realized that I
had the best success when I took out the
tank AC with machine gun fire since they
came at me first and they weren't fast
enough to dodge any of my projectiles
but fighting the other two was the real
challenge because together they were
difficult to split apart and they would
just grind me down over time so I needed
a secondary weapon that could take one
of them out quickly with overwhelming
power I chose missiles as my secondary
weapon and I also equipped a relation
missile extension part so once this
extension was activated it basically
shot out more missiles as a bonus
whenever I shot out my normal missiles
which basically doubled my damage output
for a short amount of time which was
enough time to deal a severe amount of
damage and finally even the odds but
then there was still a final piece of
this puzzle which was taking out the
third AC and this was just an ammo issue
I had a few attempts where I absolutely
destroyed the first two but simply did
not have enough ammo to finish the job
it was frustrating but eventually I made
a build with two sets of very ammo
efficient missiles and I gripped my
teeth and I took out the final AC on a
sliver of Health one missile at a time
I genuinely felt like I achieved
something here it was really rewarding
to have to discover the pieces of the
puzzle on the battlefield and then solve
that puzzle in the garage and then put
solution to the test in my opinion this
is armored Core at its best and by the
way there is a part of armored Core
six's trailer that shows the player
fighting against three enemy ACS at once
so yeah you should probably prepare
yourself for that
but then it was back to the mission
grind and credit where credit is due the
way you navigate all of the missions in
this game is very cool because there are
multiple missions for each region and
there's a good sense of familiarity and
progression in the world as a result of
that and finally I made it to the end
it's a pleasure working with you Raven
but I'm afraid at this time
I'll be honest I don't even know who
that guy is
more than in any other armored Core game
I actually kind of felt like an
independent Raven in this one just
grinding away admission after mission on
behalf of faceless corporations for
credits alone
so after spending so much time on this
game I was actually kind of appreciative
when I got this message from from
software at the end thanks Raven you've
accomplished a great feat your
achievement is recognized by us and then
they give you a well-deserved reward
more missions great
but to be fair these missions were kind
of the best of all you face off against
who I can only assume is Stinger from
project phantasma with his being all
glitchy and corrupted
I kind of like the flavor of these
ancient ACS just persisting throughout
the ages to eventually be fought as
these corrupted remnants of another age
later on
and of course the real final fight
is against nine ball Seraph again
because of course it is
and here he fights the exact same way he
does in master of Arena though the
controls and visuals are thankfully a
lot better in this game
as then he's extremely tough but here I
discover a strategy that will serve me
well in future games if you're ever
facing an AC that tries to get behind
you just back up against a wall if
fought in this manner nine ball will
chase you around the edge of the Arena
instead of just dashing behind you all
the time and he follows you around he
slashes at you with energy waves and
shoots his projectiles but you can just
dodge them with another strategy I
learned which is to Bunny Hop boosts
tightly to the left and right but even
with all this this fight was still hard
as hell and at this point I'm honestly
just kind of amazed at how much from
software likes toying with people's nine
ball PTSD by putting him in so many
games but eventually one
and surely I won't have to fight that
guy again
and that's the second generation of
armored Core games complete in
retrospect I think this might be the
hardest generation of armored Core if
you take all of the missions together
anyway next is armored Core 3 a whole
new generation and wouldn't it be great
if they finally added dual analog
controls yeah nah they still haven't
made the right analog stick useful which
is interesting but at least there's a
pretty good story this time armored Core
3 takes place during the period of
History where mankind was forced
underground because of the great
destruction here Subterranean life is
governed by the controller an AI which
quite predictably goes wild the sequel
silent line deals with the aftermath of
you destroying the controller mankind
returns to the surface and corporations
begin to fight over what lies beyond the
silent line but mysterious Technologies
are already up here on the surface and
they repel their intrusions these are
very compelling Stories the third
generation of games is quite compelling
in general actually controls and
movements get tighter with every gen and
the way the shop and the garage is
integrated is really nice menus are
faster to navigate and I could be wrong
but I felt like weight limits were way
more generous in this generation as had
less trouble fitting everything I wanted
onto my AC
said I'm not sure that there's too much
else I have to say about armored Core 3
or its sequel silent line that I kind of
haven't said already as usual there were
good missions and frustrating missions
and the final fights were great fun but
I was never really truly challenged by
anything in these games which means I
can't really point to any one thing that
made these games particularly memorable
For Me overall though I think armored
Core 3 and silent line are an excellent
starting point for beginners who want to
experience the older generation
precisely because I don't think they're
too difficult and because from software
has just added a ton of quality of life
changes to the series by this point I
will say a cool new addition in this
generation were left arm parts that
weren't just blades or Shields so in
this game you can equip your left arm
with Bazookas and rifles and tons of
really fun Weaponry these weapons fire
with a delay but being able to fire two
weapons at once can dramatically
increase your damage output and it gives
a really fun depth to builds only
problem is firing two weapons means you
have to mash Two Face buttons at once to
fire them and remember you're still
boosting with the other face button so
that's three face buttons you have to
press at once and that's just a huge
stress to your finger inputs on top of
everything else so because the series
still refused to accommodate the right
analog stick for aiming dual firing was
still uncomfortable with default
controls at least and so I just opted
for a passive shield on my left arm
instead but finally the control scheme
would be brought into the modern PS2 ERA
with generation 3.5 of armored Core
which consisted of three games Nexus 9
breaker and best of all blast Raven with
the ability to aim with the right stick
added in Nexus the L2 and R2 bumpers
were finally released from their torment
as camera operators and were able to be
used for intuitive things instead like
boosting and switching weapons which
meant that L1 and R1 instead of strafing
could be used for firing left and right
arm Weaponry respectively which meant
that dual wielding wasn't just viable it
was incredible dual firing added a new
offensive depth to the customization
that I was so ready for so I dived into
the first mission equipped with a brand
new generator and some really fast
boosters and immediately began to
overheat so temperature management had
always been a thing in previous games
but back then I only really ever
overheated when I was hit by too much
enemy Weaponry all at once and it only
did a damage over time effect if I got
too hot in armored Core Nexus that'll
went out the window now I noticed my
boosters contributing a lot to my heat
meter and if I overheated in this game
then my radiator would activate and suck
up immense amounts of my own energy in
order to cool down my AC
and that is a lot more impactful than
just taking damage over time so all of a
sudden heat management had become a huge
new consideration when considering
Weaponry generators boosters and
radiators it's almost as if from
software realized that their game had
just become easier with the new dual
stick controls and thought we can't have
that and so they added this insane
overheat mechanic in Revenge regardless
eventually I had my head around this new
heat system so I started to experiment
with new dual wielding setups I tried
double chain guns double sniper rifles
handguns laser rifles it was fun but
what I really fell in love with was dual
wielding two different weapons rather
than wielding two of the same I ended up
settling on a bazooka and rifle combo
these two had similar range which I
think is a really important thing to
think about when you're dual wielding
two different weapons but the rifle was
great for smaller faster or flying
enemies and the Bazooka was great for
the larger slower or grounded enemies
and it was also just a really fun
gameplay element to sort of practice
firing two different weapons at once
that said I ended Nexus with double
Bazookas in a fight against a very
familiar piece of ancient technology but
at this point they'd wield poor old nine
ball out so many times that hey it's not
the same anymore rest in peace old
friend
I guess it does make some sense that
nine ball would be here in this game
though as as far as I can tell the story
of Nexus is about corporations fighting
to control ancient technologies that
they don't really understand and it all
backfires in the end swarms of unmanned
suicide drones spew out of a factory and
out onto the Earth where they blanket
the world in another sort of great
destruction it's awful but it's one of
the most memorable endings that these
games have ever had in my opinion just
because of the phenomenal way that it's
presented you stand on the rooftop in
the pouring rain actually able to
control your character and fight back as
this indomitable barrage of suicide
drones Ram into you and the Earth's
surface and you make your doomed last
stand here there's no hope of you taking
them all out so you simply fight on as
the screen Fades to Black and Nexus
comes to an end
so I enjoyed Nexus but I cannot say the
same for the next expansion which is
armored Core 9 breaker so get this this
game has no missions it doesn't even
have a shop at its core is a training
mode which is filled with 150 training
exercises that test you on things like
movement evasion accuracy stuff like
that
fun that's not really armored Core to me
so I didn't really bother when I played
I figured the real point of this game
was the uniquely designed Arena mode
which requires you to earn points and
climb the ranks that way rather than
just beating the next AC in your path
but I made a terrible mistake with this
game I imported my save from Nexus and I
didn't realize this but it actually
removed all of the default parts that I
would have had in my garage and just
replaced them with what I had in Nexus
instead and I didn't have much unlocked
in Nexus so I was essentially forced to
do the entire arena with one build a
heavy biped with two Bazookas luckily my
build was just strong enough to take out
90 of my opponents but there were some
that were borderline impossible with my
build and to get to top rank by
defeating the last guy I had to wait
until he challenged me on a map where I
could stand at the Arena's Edge just so
he couldn't fly behind me and I just
took him out after countless attempts
maybe I'll do the training missions to
prepare for armored Core 6 and maybe
they'd be great if you're a beginner to
the series but I wanted to move on
because I was so excited for the next
game I had heard a lot about it it's the
last armored Core game that has this old
gen style and I'd heard that it was
perhaps the hardest game that from
software had ever created next was Ahmed
Core last Raven and it did not
disappoint
when we left off in Nexus unmanned
suicide weapons had ravaged the world
the corporations had lost everything but
instead of trying to rebuild
individually they joined forces to form
a new Corporation Called Alliance but a
rebel group known as vertex vowed to
overthrow them and War quickly escalated
into chaos now vertex has issued a
declaration their final attack will
launch in 24 hours so it is that last
Raven starts with a clear story and a
foreboding timer that counts down after
every Mission building the tension last
Raven also perfects the mission
structure in my opinion offering a set
of missions that if done in the right
order push you towards different
missions and different endings I really
liked being able to take a more active
role in the story based on which path I
chose in this game
so many of my memories with armored Core
so far had been born from my challenges
in these games so in this playthrough I
opted to go down a story path that I had
heard was the hardest of them all it's
called the Zenaida path named after your
rival who challenges you in a ton of
these missions so I knew it would get
hard I was prepared for that you know
but what I wasn't prepared for was for
the first mission to literally be harder
than anything I'd faced in the previous
two games
like to put this into context I had just
imported my build from line breaker and
this AC design with its dual Bazookas
this had taken me through the entirety
of that game it had taken me through the
entirety of Nexus as well and yet I was
struggling with the first mission in
last Raven with this build
So eventually I took a step back and I
realized I needed to perfect my AC
further if I was going to take on these
missions so I took a few steps back
actually and I went all the way back to
the first disc of Nexus where I farmed
credits for a few hours just so I could
buy every part in the shop then I went
into the second disc of Nexus which had
some optional parts that I had missed
and in these missions I found an
insanely powerful Ananda radiator to
stop me from overheating and also found
something called a linear rifle which
was kind of like a halfway point between
a bazooka and a rifle it had good stun
capabilities and it helped my offhand
weapon hit more reliably and it would be
at my side for the entirety of last
Raven actually I also discovered a type
of missile called micro missiles which
send a barrage of smaller missiles out
which makes them great for overwhelming
enemies with anti-missile systems built
into their core or built into their
extensions and with this setup I was
eventually able to kite the enemy AC
named bolt around the arena staying just
out of range of his cannons and
unloading everything I had every circuit
around the battlefield I would take some
time to hide and recover energy behind
these buildings and then I would start
the circuit again it was close but I had
completed the first mission
or at least I thought I had
I didn't know what was going on I
thought I had broken some crucial part
of my AC here and I thought the audio
was glitching out as a result because
last Raven did add a new feature where
you can break certain body parts on your
build during battle so for a minute
there I thought this experience was very
immersive it was like wow the head
part's broken and my audios glitched
that's amazing
but my disc was actually scratched so
that'll teach me to buy things off eBay
I guess my mission flat out refused to
end so I reset my PS2 managed to beat
the mission again and the same glitch
did happen but at least it let me finish
the mission this time
surely this won't be an issue later
right
as was tradition whenever I knew I
needed to get stronger I took on the
arena and to my surprise I flew through
almost all of it with no issue I even
added some heavy bipedal legs that I
chose for their excellent boost speed
despite how heavy they were which helped
to offset the issues that I had with my
slow movements since I was just bunny
hopping most of the time anyway so I
would activate my EO core and get these
little floating turrets and then I'd
unload all my micro missiles and my
relation missiles and then I'd purged
all my missiles and drop them to lighten
my load and increase my speed before
transitioning to linear rifle and
bazooka and kiting my enemy around for
the win few stood a chance against this
build and so my enemies weren't really
that memorable as a result although one
of the funniest builds I faced in this
Arena was some guy with the hover
extension part who had built an infinite
flight killed his build was pretty
useless and very easy to shoot at in the
sky but it was interesting and I didn't
know that that was possible but then
everything became incredibly difficult
when I met the guy at the top of the
Arena Damon and I think this guy might
take the title for being the best pilot
I had faced in these games just look at
his technique he's a god
by combining a close range machine gun
with some sort of bazooka Damon is
essentially able to stun lock you to
death in no time at all and because he's
so Adept at flying at close range it's
an absolute nightmare trying to keep him
in your sights even with these new
analog controls I died to him over and
over and over and I felt true despair
because this wasn't like previous games
I couldn't choose the arena in last
Raven I couldn't just put him in the
garage and call it a day no this Arena
was perfectly suited to his aerial
strengths
tried a few new things against Damon I
tried equipping an overboost core to
help me get some distance but then my
energy would run out and he would close
in I even tried a vertical FCS part for
the first time which gave me this tall
lock box that was a bit better suited to
Damon's movement trajectory but nope not
enough I was about to give up and come
back later but then I had an idea I
thought back to that hover AC that I had
laughed at just a few hours ago and
wondered what if that was the key what
if I built something like that if I
could get up onto the roof and stay
there then I'd be able to completely
negate Damon's aerial Supremacy I
thought there was at least a chance this
would work so I went into the garage
with all my parts and got to work
luckily last Raven includes the ability
for you to tune most parts to be better
in line with your specific build
requirements but even so this Infinite
Flight build turned out to be extremely
tricky to me but it taught me a lot
first I needed the build to be able to
get me high into the air so I chose
reverse bipedal legs for their Superior
jumping then I needed a generator with
enough capacity and boosters that had
enough power to get me to the roof then
I needed my build to be energy efficient
enough to keep my hover extension active
so that I could stay hovering this meant
that I needed to choose parts that had
low energy drain as every part takes
away from your generator's maximum
output eventually I had a build that was
so energy efficient it could float in
the air and recover energy slowly as
well
then the final problem was to cram
Weaponry onto this thing without it
weighing or draining me down I needed
weapons that were light ammo efficient
and with a lot of range I eventually
settled on micro missiles and a sniper
rifle and then after so much trial and
failure I had it I called this AC
vulture after the way it sort of circles
around its foes out of range and it
eventually took me to Victory against
Damon with literally zero ammo to spare
I guess you could argue I choose this
fight but it didn't feel like it because
armored core's gameplay begins in the
garage and I felt super proud of this
win because it felt like I had solved a
really complex puzzle
for now I put vulture away and I pulled
out my blast Raven build instead and I
got back to the missions by the way
that's another cool thing about last
Raven you're able to save and load
different builds quickly it's as if you
have different mechs just sitting in
your Hangar waiting to be taken out when
it's their time to shine being able to
load specific builds is an amazing
feature for these games to have as it
stops you having to Tinker with your
build in the menus for ages instead you
can build Solutions name them get
attached to them and then be ready to
switch up your gameplay style whenever
those builds are perfect for the
situation at hand armored Core 6 had
better have a system like this I swear
even Elden ring should have a system
like this another thing armored Core 6
should take from last Raven is its
in-game lore repository which is just a
great way for players to recap the story
in game you know this way they don't
have to rely on over dramatic YouTube
Rivers for all their law
maybe don't put that in the game last
Raven's missions were a delight actually
the best I'd experienced so far almost
everyone was peppered with familiar
enemy ACS that would show up or betray
you and missions were just these great
tests of your combat efficiency rather
than having you run around the map for
obscure objectives that said there was
one bad Mission which plunged me into
pure Blackness after a maze of corridors
which made it borderline impossible to
escape this place without having a
headpiece that had night vision on it
which I didn't have so that was pretty
lame but throughout all of these
missions I'd actually been putting up
with something even more painful
remember that glitch that showed up on
my first mission where audio would bug
out and the mission wouldn't end well
that had been happening this whole time
and a lot of missions I had to repeat
and eventually it became so bad that I
found one mission that just wouldn't end
again and again and again I completed
this Mission and it refused to move on
until I gave up I couldn't progress I
had to suck it up and put away the PS2
and use an emulator to finish last Raven
instead
okay so you might be noticing a
difference in the quality of the visuals
looking back I really regret not trying
emulators sooner this was kind of
amazing with the right settings last
Raven runs at a higher frame rate plays
at a sharper resolution and I was even
able to use save states to help me get
back to where I was in the missions
faster it hurt having to do all these
missions again but I was enjoying the
gameplay even more than before listen I
love old hardware and if I had just used
emulators then I might have been tempted
to use save states to overcome crucial
moments of difficulty and tedium and if
I had run these games at a silky smooth
60fps and high resolutions the games
would have been a lot easier and looked
a lot better than they really are I
wouldn't have experienced them the same
way everyone else did all those years
ago but all that said I'd still
recommend emulating these games over
buying scratched overpriced discs on
eBay eBay has atrocious buyer support
and they won't let me get a refund for
this scratch disk so yeah don't do that
anyway eventually I made it to the final
mission a final Gauntlet that requires
you to dodge through these long hallways
filled with suicide drones and then
eventually I actually got a checkpoint
for the first time in armored Core so I
didn't have to reset from the start
anymore but I just had to take out some
lasers on the walls and then it was the
final fight with Zenaida here she is
widely regarded to be the most difficult
fight in this game and I'll let you
watch and figure out why
she fights a lot like Damon except I
think she's even faster than him but she
does fight at more of a mid-range and
she has these energy weapons that
overheat you and somehow don't slow her
down at all like the best enemy ACS I'm
pretty sure she's just cheating because
there's no way you can build an AC that
could match her movement and Firepower
right not to mention you have to start
this fight at low health because of the
suicide drones unless you make it past
the drones without taking damage which
is what I did I spent ages learning the
Drone patterns and then managed to
somehow get to the checkpoint with full
health then I just had to solve the
Zenaida fight somehow I knew I couldn't
outrun her with my heavy AC so I came up
with a new strategy I realized that if I
moved forwards and backwards like this
then she would fly into my sights for a
brief moment just long enough for me to
get off a salvo of missiles and then for
the first time I was actually dealing
consistent damage to her but would it be
enough it required precise inputs
perfect aim and by the end I was
gripping my controller so hard that my
hands hurt but then at 500 AP
I got it the final shot
the sun sets on you as the last Raven
finally I'd completed every game in
these old Generations next was the
fourth generation and it was here that
the series would change forever
for a new game director had entered the
scene
that's right armored Core 4 and armored
Core for Answer are directed by none
other than hirataka Miyazaki himself and
in his new very different fourth
generation of armored Core Raven Pilots
are no more they've been superseded by
Links who Pilots next new and improved
armored cores that can move and fly and
fight on a whole other level I mean just
look at how fast they are the reason
this combat is so much more intense is
because a it's now much easier to attain
Infinite Flight and keep your boosters
on at all times and B side boosts now
have a dedicated button rather than
being a niche extension part that only
moved you in One Direction what's more
canceling your boosters and tapping side
boost can allow you to perform a quick
turn maneuver giving skilled players the
means to keep enemies in their sights
during this frantic combat having these
boosts built into the default controls
was in my opinion a huge step forward
for the franchise and of all the games
these are the ones that Ivory played the
most having six full playthroughs under
my belt to date and while armored Core 4
is great and I really enjoyed putting
together this energy weapon build that
dual wields pulse guns only to throw
them away when they're out of ammo and
reveal a backup set of two more pulse
guns that was fun most of my
playthroughs are actually in Thor's
sequel which is armored Core for answer
because I feel like it's here in this
game that the true potential of this
generation was fully realized not just
in gameplay but in storytelling and tone
as well so for the first time I want to
start by talking about the music in this
game to be fair the music and armored
Core has always been great you've been
hearing it all throughout this video
after all and a lot of the credit for
that seems to have to to go to a man
named Kota hoshino who composed on
almost all of these soundtracks he even
runs a band called frequency whose music
releases overlap almost entirely with
the armored Core franchise and its
distinct sound and that's so cool it's
cool that armored Core has its own
in-house band that plays for it it also
seems like Kota hoshino has been working
with from software ever since so I
really hope that his band creates some
music for armored Core 6 because the
music was always good but something
specifically changed with generation 4's
music especially with foranza where many
songs play with this Melancholy
nostalgic almost haunting sound to them
and it added such a good vibe to the
franchise I mean just listen to this
these sort of reflective songs play in a
lot of key missions and I feel like
they're trying to get you to ask the
why why are we fighting are we really
doomed to have all of this Destruction
play out over and over and over again
and the answer is inevitably yes despite
their promise humanity is doomed and in
fact Ahmed Kaur for answer actually has
one of the darkest most disturbing
endings that from software has ever
directed and I want to show it to you
thing is you can only get this unique
ending if you complete the game three
times so that's why I decided to replay
for answer so many times and I'm so glad
I did because these new game plus
missions are some of the best in the
franchise and replaying the game so many
times helped me to play closer to that
insanely High skill ceiling that the
fourth generation lays claim to
s ranking certain missions rewarded me
with new parts and replaying so many
times also gave me a ton of FRS points
to invest which are basically these stat
points that allow you to level up and
further tune the performance of your AC
by the end I was over boosting side
boosting and just fighting with a speed
and precision that I'm honestly quite
proud of looking back the reason my
overboost looks so cool here is because
I'm using a core from the legendary
white glint which gives it a unique
animation white glint is for answer's
cover character and they're a legendary
character in this generation so because
I was taking parts from this Mech I
jokingly called my next Black flint and
actually ended up becoming pretty
attached to this build over the course
of three playthroughs black Flint is
equipped with dual machine gun arms
which fire both Chambers with R1 and
despite these weapons being extremely
powerful on their own you're still
allowed to fire a back weapon at the
same time so I ended up equipping the
yamaga a grenade launcher that fires
from the back here and it's really fun
firing the machine guns constantly while
always looking out for the perfect
moment to fire a grenade if my aim was
good enough I could destroy enemies so
quickly that their dialogue couldn't
even finish in time not to mention the
other parts I chose allowed not only for
Infinite Flight but basically infinite
side boosting as well making me
extremely difficult to hit and then
there's my shoulder attachments where I
opted for the Euphoria which increase my
Primal armor but what is Primal armor
well this is your Primal armor it's a
regenerating resource that primarily
reduces the damage you take but it's
also a resource that you can dip into
for overboosting like this or using
assault armor like this and I think it's
important you understand that because
all signs indicate that armored Core 6
will have some successor to Primal armor
as well since you can see it repelling
attacks here in the trailer
and you can see a similar assault armor
explosion here and here as well Primal
armor is a Technology based on Kojima
particles which are extremely pollutive
to the point where Primal armor is
actually strictly banned in inhabited
areas as the mere after effect of a next
fighting in this space could contaminate
this area for generations to come now a
lot of our fights do take place near
high-rise apartment buildings but not to
worry they've almost always been long
enveloped by the ocean through a desert
Wasteland sapped of color and life as
after all very little of mankind
actually remains on the Earth's
poisonous surface instead long ago most
of humankind fled to the cradles which
are these massive Airship colonies each
holding at least 20 million members of
humankind who escaped the pollution
below so that they could live in the
Clean Air Above but according to the
Revolutionary group called Orca
maintaining the cradles is actually
causing horrible pollution on the
surface and its orca's belief that
pollution will soon start bleeding into
the atmosphere itself where the cradles
fly so Orca seeks to commandeer the
energy sources powering the cradles and
use that energy for a different purpose
they wish to power an array of
anti-satellite cannons and turn them
Towards the Sky in an attempt to take
out an Interstellar web of assault cells
that are blocking Mankind's Escape to
Space because Orca thinks this world is
doomed but in your first playthrough
you're actually given no choice other
than to side with the league
establishment who are attempting to
prevent orca from taking away the
cradle's energy source the final fight
has you defend those energy sources here
in arteria Cranium where you fight
against two enemy nexts so on your
second playthrough you'll find New
Missions to play and these lead to the
Orca ending where you actually end up on
the opposite side attempting to rest the
power sources of these cradles from The
Establishment in this ending the cradles
are forced to land subjecting mother and
child to the pollution they had escaped
in the skies and even as humanity is
decimated down here they will discover a
new frontier I outer space
but there's a third ending one that's
only open to you if you take on Orca
members in their Arena mode until you
meet and defeat an enemy pilot known
only as old King he's a radical Orca
member who takes a more direct approach
to things and so a new Mission pops up
on your board in this playthrough
s
[Music]
in a revolution
good you came how obedient of you
fell the cradles all of them
Millions will die exciting don't you
think this mission is easy the only
challenge to you here is from your
conscience As Old King who Revels in the
Bloodshed one down 20 million dead
40 million
60 million
18 million
100 million
[Music]
done
there are still so many more lives to
take our journey is just beginning
but finally your Reckoning arrives in
the last mission you're led into an
ambush against a United force of foes
who are disgusted with your actions you
and Old King have to face off against
four enemy nexts and if you're doing
this in hard mode there's even a fifth
this is an extremely challenging fight
even for my build which I thought was
quite overpowered until this point but
somehow I take out three enemy nexts and
then the fourth gets stuck Beyond the
Wall separated from myself and Old King
who has somehow survived but rather than
wait for my Ally to get unstuck I dive
into combat on low health
and just make it out alive it was
nerve-wracking this fight but I felt
like I came out of it a better player
and I think one day I'd love to come
back and attempt hard mode where there's
tons of unique twists to missions things
are harder in interesting ways like
adding new mechs to the fights so for
answer easily ranks within my top three
AC games alongside last Raven and master
of Arena and I really would love to play
it again now if it wasn't obvious
already from the footage I emulated most
of my four answer playthrough that's
because my disc wouldn't play voice
audio for some reason and it kind of
ruined my first playthrough but I will
say being able to emulate this game
without any FPS lag probably played a
huge part in why I came to like this
game so much because performance on the
PS3 version is not on the same level so
many of these missions are so epic in
scale like taking out these enormous
armed Sports and
they should be incredible experiences
but they really do put the old gen
Hardware to shame unfortunately so
emulate these games if you can that said
I've heard it's really hard to emulate
the next couple of games on this list
and these are pretty much the last games
that I want to talk about in depth here
because finally we've arrived at the
fifth and for the longest time it was
the final generation it's time to talk
about armored Core 5 and its sequel
verdict Day
whereas 4th gen's music was toned for a
beautiful Melancholy in 5th gen your
garage sessions are instead accompanied
by a thumping militaristic beat that
glorifies war a theme that is absolutely
reinforced by the gameplay and story as
well because armored Core 5 marks
another huge generational shift except
this time it's in the direction of
making armored Core more of a Mech War
simulator rather than the mechanized
power fantasy that it was in the fourth
generation and while this new style
would absolutely grow on me especially
in five's sequel verdict Day I'm gonna
be honest and say I really did not enjoy
my time with armored Core 5. to be fair
the game was largely designed as a
multiplayer experience but there is
still a single player and I don't think
it's very good I found FPS performance
to be lacking I thought the visual
clutter on the screen was atrocious I
didn't really feel like I could outplay
my enemies and the missions were long
and lackluster with character dialogue
that kind of made me cringe the most fun
I had in this game was because of my
build because For the First Time really
I chose a really heavy tank build loaded
with auto cannons and heavy rifles I
figured if there was ever a time for a
slow build it was in this generation
where I disliked the movement style so
might as well not move much at all and
work that into my build and I will say I
love the new feature that allowed me to
charge into enemies with my tank legs
for massive damage this is kind of like
the move you can see the tank build do
here in the armored Core 6 trailer so I
had fun with my build even if I didn't
like the game too much but in the final
mission of almond Core 5 I saw a brief
glimpse of how good the combat could be
in this fight you have time to preempt
and Dodge attacks and learning the
boss's moveset and attack patterns was
quite rewarding and honestly something
that I hadn't really experienced much of
before in Ahmed core and luckily five's
sequel verdict Day clearly learned a lot
of lessons from five so instead of
complaining about five I'd much rather
talk about what I enjoyed in verdict Day
and I'll properly explain the gameplay
via my experiences with that game
instead just like for answers soundtrack
verdict Day's songs are absolutely
iconic
listen to this beat
it's not just the action tracks the
karma garage and menu tracks are so
memorable to me now as well so I'll let
those play while I take you through the
garage of the fifth generation in 5th
gen you basically begin with one part in
every category making it easy to try new
weapons and equipment to try and figure
out what build you like the catch all of
these parts are junk like literally
they're classified as junk parts and
they're weaker than everything else that
you can get in the shop but I think this
is smart design because it means that at
the start of the game you can't really
go wrong with anything that you buy in
the shop because no matter what you do
it's probably going to be an upgrade
from what you have it's a clever way to
onboard new players in my opinion and it
gives you a really clear sense of
progression especially at the start of
the game when that's very important and
I wonder if they'll do something like
this in armored Core 6 we do see a
character Scavenging parts from the
battlefield at the start after all the
first mission to give me trouble in
verdict Day actually shaped my entire
build for the rest of my playthrough
because I couldn't kill these guys and
the only solution I found that would
work was sniping them and I was really
happy to go with a sniper build because
that was another archetype I hadn't
really figured out in previous games
until now I it works well in this game
specifically because it's very easy to
get horizontal distance from your
opponents in this game and also the
gameplay is just generally more tactical
in generation 5 with great rewards for
careful positioning which only got
better given I could snipe enemies from
really far away so let me explain the
combat in this generation your boosters
can be toggled on or off allowing you to
either Glide or walk and if you're
gliding on the ground then you're able
to activate Glide Boost which is
essentially an overboost that moves you
around at an extreme speed at the
expense of more energy then finally
there's quick boost which is kind of
like the side Boost from armored Core 4
but worse and then I guess you could
also include jumping in this discussion
because jumping is also extremely
important for movement in this
generation as jumping up buildings is
your primary means of
height of your opponents because you
actually can't boost upwards in this
game for very long and also jumping
perpendicular off buildings is also one
of the fastest ways to move horizontally
and looking back it's honestly kind of
absurd that there are four separate
buttons just for moving around the map
in this game Ahmad core has always been
a series that is really stressful on
your controller inputs but the fifth
generation kind of takes it too far in
my opinion not to mention another
essential part of combat is scan mode
which you can toggle on or off with R3
in this mode you can't fire your weapons
but your energy output skyrockets
allowing builds to quickly recover
energy or just to be way more evasive
for a long period of time I would use
this whenever I needed to get distance
from my enemies and then I would go back
into combat mode for sniping of course
the other use for scan mode is you know
scanning which is also very important
that's because there are three damage
types in the fifth generation kinetic
thermal and chemical and in retrospect
it's essential that you scan enemies
especially bosses because it's essential
that you choose Weaponry that can
overwhelm their unique defenses
otherwise you'll see the words
ineffective whenever you hit them and
your weapons will just tickle them
instead now I was lazy and I rarely felt
like scanning so there were a lot of
enemies that I just tickled to death
instead honestly I don't like the scan
system because I love when armored Core
forces you to reconsider your broader
strategy and to experiment with things
but I don't think there's much
creativity involved when you're forced
to just choose a weapon that enemies are
weak to it just felt like rock paper
scissors the entire game and I didn't
really enjoy this damage system very
much what I did like in this game was
the addition of Unix which are these AI
companions that you can choose to bring
with you into missions there's some
really fun strategy involved in choosing
a complementary Ally for your build for
example I chose a unac that would tank
and take aggro from me while I sniped in
the distance and this made the game way
more enjoyable to play in the previous
game I felt like I was just this bullet
sponge that couldn't evade properly but
here the Unix actually enabled a lot of
strategy which is great but even unex
can only do so much against the final
boss who was perhaps unsurprisingly at
this point the most memorable part of
armored Core verdict Day for me because
he was so difficult I spent a lot of
time trying to figure this guy out he's
essentially piloting a next from armored
Core 4 and it is terrifying to go
against it makes you realize just how
powerful those things were back then its
strength lies mostly in its Primal armor
which is almost impossible to break
through in the first phase until it goes
in for assault armor which leaves it
vulnerable for a short moment I
eventually figured out that if I dashed
in and took a bit of damage here I could
end phase one in an instant because I
decided to use dual pile drivers which
with these short melee weapons that
essentially Ram a warhead deep into the
body of your opponent for insane damage
it's very similar to what you see here
in the ac6 trailer actually then phase
two begins and you have to play out of
your mind in order to succeed in this
phase you have to activate scan mode and
overboost to evade those missiles and
then you have to deal damage whenever he
stands still and make sure you're at the
perfect range as well and also try to
keep the sun behind you because God that
sun is obnoxious this fight is long and
you'll take a lot of unavoidable damage
so you have to really play perfectly in
order to deal enough damage in time and
take him out overall I enjoyed verdict
Day just as much as any other armored
Core game and I think with it they
really perfected a lot of design
decisions and it goes to show just how
much the sequels are some Sometimes the
best of each generation in armored Core
rather than just being more of the same
and I think if you don't play the
sequels you are really missing out
but I'm actually not done yet because
the Last Frontier was this
formula front extreme battle on the PSP
I never had a PSP when I was younger so
I was not going to pass up this
opportunity to buy one there are four
armored Core games on the PSP but three
of these AC3 silent line and last Raven
these are remakes the unique PSP title
is this one formula front extreme battle
where you're given every single part
from the get-go and you're simply tasked
with climbing the ranks in the arena the
catch with this game is that you can
technically beat this game without
actually playing it as there's a whole
system of AI coding where you calibrate
your AC to fight for you
sounds good in theory but these AI menus
take forever to navigate and often your
AC won't listen to your preset commands
and they'll just happily shoot missiles
into a wall instead while you're forced
to watch so I played through half the
game manually and I will say the enemy
ACS in this game are really really well
designed their builds are very unique
and I ended up being forced to make four
drastically different builds in order to
progress and counter them it was really
fun but one funny thing about this game
is the whole aesthetic that it has while
every other game is this dystopian
commentary on the terror of War and the
dispassion of business the music and the
intros in Formula front make you feel
like you've entered a race in Gran
Turismo with an audience of adoring fans
watching in anticipation as the
announcer shouts go with Glee it's weird
if this is what peacetime looks like in
the armored Core Universe then I'll take
the dystopian corporate nightmare please
so in conclusion I like armored Core and
some of these games I even loved again
my top three in the end were master of
Arena last Raven and foranza and I'm
very thankful that I have all of you
guys and this channel as that's what
motivated me to push through and
understand this franchise because of
that I discovered a genre of games that
I otherwise might have never discovered
and I think it's a shame that so many
other people haven't tried these games
so I hope this video might help to
convince a few people to give them a try
and to push through any hardships that
they'll face so that you can get some
mechanized memories of your own so to
speak so again if you want to play
anything from this series either see if
you can get a fair price for them second
hand or just emulate and if you do
emulate be prepared for some technical
fiddling with settings for some of these
games but it should all be pretty
possible with Guides Online duckstation
is best for the PS1 game
pcsx2 is the best for PS2 and RPC S3 is
best for PlayStation 3. and if you are
interested well which game should you
play
that is actually not a very easy
question to answer I think if you only
have time to play one armored Core game
then I would recommend starting in the
fourth generation with armored Core for
Answer it's probably the easiest single
game to get to grips with and it has
fantastic depth if you do decide to do
multiple playthroughs but if you have
time to play a couple of games then I'd
recommend that you play Armored Core 3
and silent line these felt quite
accessible to me but if you really want
dual analog controls and a challenge
then I'd recommend both discs of armored
Core Nexus and then last Raven instead
but of course this is just all my
speculation play any from this video
that sound interesting to you you really
can't go too wrong if you're dedicated
enough
okay maybe don't play nine breaker or
formula front but that's about it
but thank you for listening to this
extremely long video
I hope it gets you hyped for armored
Core 6 playing all these games
definitely has got me excited but anyway
I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign
thank you